[Música]
y bienvenidos a este programa especial
de áfrica siete días en france 24 mi
nombre liliana valencia y hoy hablaremos
acerca de los impactos en el continente
africano de los atentados del 11 de
septiembre de 2001 en eeuu
ese día 19 integrantes del grupo
terrorista al-qaeda se tomaron el
control de cuatro aviones llenos de
pasajeros y los estrellaron contra las
torres gemelas de nueva york la sede del
pentágono en washington y a las afueras
de la ciudad de pensilvania un total de
dos mil novecientos setenta y siete
personas perdieron la vida en estos
atentados dos mil 753 de ellas en las
torres gemelas de nueva york
184 en el pentágono y 40 en los campos
de pensilvania
sin embargo los primeros ataques del
grupo al qaeda y su líder osama bin
laden contra eeuu tuvieron lugar en el
continente africano y marcaron la
relación de la unión americana con
países como sudán a continuación les
presentamos la historia
unas imágenes que 20 años después sigue
conmocionando al mundo
el rostro de un enemigo que le quitó el
sueño a eeuu por años
pese a que el ataque del 11 de
septiembre de 2001 es el más recordado
no fue el primero que bin laden perpetró
contra eeuu
[Música]
los primeros atentados a gran escala de
al qaeda tocaron las puertas de áfrica
el 7 de agosto de 1998 las embajadas de
eeuu en kenia y tanzania sufrieron
ataques simultáneos
[Música]
en estos actos de violencia terrorista
son aborrecibles son inhumanos
utilizaremos todos los medios a nuestro
alcance para llevar a los responsables
ante la justicia no importa qué o cuánto
tiempo lleve que text
en los ataques contra las embajadas en
nairobi y dar es salam murieron al menos
213 personas y resultaron heridas cerca
de 5000 sólo habían pasado algunos días
de los atentados y los organismos de
inteligencia ya apuntaban a grupos
extremistas islámicos
[Música]
y nuestra misión es clara atacar la red
de grupos radicales afiliados y
financiados por osama bin laden quizás
el principal organizador y financiero
del terrorismo internacional en el mundo
el contraataque de eeuu puso en la mira
a dos países afganistán y ciudad los
días posteriores al ataque la aviación
estadounidense bombardeó objetivos de la
red de bin laden una contraofensiva que
desató la ira del entonces presidente de
sudán omar al-bashir
[Música]
condenamos estas acciones recalcamos que
el pueblo sudanés seguirá respondiendo a
esto con acciones similares este crimen
atroz no va a pasar sin impunidad vamos
a presentar nuestra denuncia por los
canales oficiales de la onu
después de un acalorado discurso al
bachir y unos 500 manifestantes fueron a
la embajada británica arrojaron piedras
y se tomaron parte de la edificación
[Música]
dos años después de los atentados contra
las embajadas un nuevo ataque orquestado
por al qaeda con la protección del
gobierno sudanés estremecería a eeuu
[Música]
el 12 de octubre del año 2000 el
destructor de la marina estadounidense
uss scouts sufrió un ataque suicida que
acabó con la vida de 17 soldados en el
puerto de adén en yemen
el hecho que ocurrió antes de las
elecciones presidenciales que
enfrentaron al demócrata al gore y el
republicano george w.bush también dejó
39 personas heridas
[Música]
las varias sanciones económicas y 27
años en la lista de países
patrocinadores de terrorismo estados
unidos retomó relaciones con sudán quien
debió pagar a washington
335 millones de dólares en compensación
por los atentados
para analizar esta información nos
comunicamos con manuel inglés profesor
de la sociedad de estudios
internacionales experto en historia del
sahel norte de áfrica y medio oriente
quien se conecta con atrás 24 desde
madrid españa bienvenido a este programa
especial y empecemos por explicar en
nuestra audiencia de donde surge la
relación entre los atentados del 11 de
septiembre de 2001 con eeuu en eeuu
justamente con el continente africano y
los grupos terroristas que se encuentran
en el continente desde hace ya un poco
más de dos décadas
hola buenas noches un placer estar aquí
con 23 buenas conexiones establecen por
supuestos hombres del continente
africano exactamente desde el cairo es
en egipto donde van a hacer esta
mentalidad map radical con los hermanos
musulmanes es ahora a partir de esta
sociedad cuando se van a extender estos
lazos hacia afganistán y hacia arabia
saudí- tanto con lazos a través de la
universidad donde estudia bin laden y
recibe estiramiento de hermanos
musulmanes atrae su profesor como hannah
actitud hermano del famosos allí youtube
y luego algunos alumnos de esa
universidad de al azhar de el cairo que
son por ejemplo rabbani el que fue
presidente durante el período de los
muyahidines en afganistán y que
actualmente sí que son de protagonista
también de los acuerdos que hay en
afganistán vemos entonces como esta
ramificación de mentalidad pues se van
radicación de los años 70 80 y 90
acabando con los atentados que hemos
escuchado de kennet antonia y también
con atentados lleven y otros muchos que
no hemos nombrado hoy bueno pero
justamente vamos a hablar de los
atentados a las embajadas de kenia y
tanzania
en el año de 1998 que marcaba el inicio
de una confrontación entre eeuu y al
qaida pero se pudieron haber tomado como
una advertencia usted cree que eeuu
dimensión o lo que se venía después de
esos atentados en esos países de
africanos
bueno ciertamente la apertura un poquito
de mente de los servicios de
inteligencia mundiales fue con dos
atentados por kenia y tanzania años 98
pero yo creo que ninguno de los 600
licencias mundiales supo canalizar
exactamente la importancia que va a
tener luego el movimiento yihadista
aumentos radicales en el mundo tanto en
áfrica en europa como en oriente medio
yo creo que no ha habido con ningún tema
análisis con esa prospectiva tan
profunda como para llegar a entender lo
que se ha producido y ahora que hemos
llegado en este año 2021 bueno ahora
cuéntanos muy brevemente a seguir con la
siguiente pregunta qué tanta injerencia
tenía al qaeda para entonces el
continente africano recordemos que
hablamos del año de 1998
en el año 98 lo que tenía al qaeda era
un entrenamiento en sudán bin laden
tenía conexiones tanto con pakistán como
con sudán en esos años y luego fue a
través del coronel omar al bachir cuando
le da el golpe de estado en su vez se
coloca en el poder permite la entrada de
bin laden para que de alguna manera
monte un campo de entrenamiento y
financiando también las acciones del
futuro grupo terrorista más potente de
aquellos años al qaeda bueno pero más
allá del análisis histórico de los
atentados de al qaeda contra objetivos
estadounidenses tanto en su territorio
como en países africanos qué
consecuencias tienen éstos en la
actualidad lo que veremos a continuación
hoy en día la región de asia occidental
a la altura del sahel sufre con especial
intensidad la presencia de grupos
armados islamistas radicales países como
burkina faso níger nigeria y malí luchan
desde hace varios años contra facciones
como boko haram o afiliados a isis
mientras que en áfrica oriental naciones
como somalia intentan defenderse de la
injerencia violenta de grupos como al
shabab el continente africano sufre uno
de los peores momentos en cuanto a
violencia terrorista durante la última
década sólo en 2020 fueron perpetrados
cuatro mil 958 ataques terroristas
liderados por grupos islamistas
radicales los cuales dejaron 13 mil 59
personas fallecidas según cifras del
centro africano de estudios estratégicos
pensamos con nuestro invitado manuel
inglés en este especial informativo para
preguntarle sobre la situación actual
del continente africano frente a la
lucha contra el terrorismo islamista y
su relación con los atentados del 11 de
septiembre de 2001 el continente
africano atraviesa un difícil momento en
cuanto a la presencia de grupos
islamistas radicales y su accionar en
diferentes regiones esto a pesar de los
esfuerzos de las diferentes naciones
africanas y la presencia de tropas
extranjeras como es el caso de la fuerza
abarcan por medio de la cual francia ha
venido apoyando la lucha contra estos
grupos insurgentes en la región del
sahel porque ha sido tan difícil cambiar
que este este este devenir histórico y
por qué ha sido tan difícil combatir a
los grupos que ejercen su terrorismo en
esta región
sin principio que comprender que es al
qaeda la que empieza a surgir en el
norte de áfrica a través de los
retornados que vienen después de la
guerra de afganistán empiezan a
radicalizarse tanto en argelia en túnez
sobre todo también en libia o en ese
famoso grupo armado libio de combate
libio también en egipto y todo esto se
empieza a contagiarse el norte de áfrica
partida que empiezan a bajar hacia la
zona de mali níger nigeria burkina faso
etcétera creando una serie de redes de
grupos divididos en dos facciones
principalmente al qaeda y actualmente de
año 2014 también da es pero lo que nos
complica muchísimo es
comprender cómo piensan y cómo actúan
estos grupos estos grupos tienen una
forma de actuar sobre todo con
filiaciones y conexiones familiares y
sobre todo religiosas evidentemente a
través de un islam radicalizado por lo
cual ha producido que se aprecie como ha
dicho usted
esta zona de áfrica la que nos atentados
en estos últimos años y el aumento de
más un incremento sustancial en el
número de víctimas y número de atentados
en estos presos que usan mucho bueno
pero sobre la región del magreb en el
norte de áfrica se registra durante los
últimos años un debilitamiento al menos
aparente de los grupos islamistas
armados a qué se debe esta situación
y debilitado ha sido en la parte de
marruecos y argelia por sus políticas de
seguridad que han sido bastante
efectivas
también se ha debilitado un poquito
últimamente en
túnez que están cogiendo en medio fuerza
en la frontera con libia libia ya sea en
ese país que ha estado muchos años desde
el año 2011 hasta una situación muy
grave desestabilizada con lo cual eso
permite muchísimo y favorece la
presencia y actuación de grupos
yihadistas
egipto ha consiguió reforzar la
seguridad gracias a la entrada de un
gobierno más fuerte como el general sí
sí aunque tenga presencia de grupos
terroristas sobre todo en el sinaí pero
en las dos esos grupos han ido
desplazando hacia el sur hacia la zona
del sahel teniendo más actuación en
estos casos en países como malí y países
que no tienen presencia ni especiales
terroristas yihadistas anteriormente
como son burkina faso o algunos países
de alrededor níger nigeria ante nigeria
tenga un grupo importante como puede ser
el boko haram en sus frentes por lo cual
hemos que la presencia de los yihadistas
en el norte se ha debilitado gracias a
las políticas de seguridad sobre todo de
marruecos y
bueno pues agradecemos al profesor
manuel inglés docente de la sociedad de
estudios internacionales y experto en
historia del sahel norte de áfrica y
medio oriente por estar en este especial
informativo en france 24 a propósito de
los 20 años de los atentados del 11 de
septiembre de 2001 en eeuu y también de
su influencia en el continente africano
tanto a nivel histórico como en la
actualidad ustedes pueden continuar con
más en nuestra página web www punto
frente a 24 punto com para ampliar la
información de américa latina y en el
mundo quédense con nosotros nos vemos
más adelante
[Música]